I Adam welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
are you doing better than I deserve
what's up I know I got that question but
I had a suggestion to series talking
about great side jobs and a great side
job is like referee and for youth sports
and you know be like I can do like a two
hour two and a half hour and I'll make
sixty bucks doing an older kid game so
that's always again I always need refs
but I always wanted to suggest that as a
great you know side job you think it's a
good one but the question I had is it
got like three or four years ago I heard
you talk about like seven I think it was
seven goals that you should sort of set
for the new year and now that we're
getting close to the new year I can't
find that podcast anymore I lost a list
and I wanted to know if you could just
sort of lay out the seven goals or maybe
those eight goals that you should sort
of have different was different
categories for the new year and talk
about that okay I'll try to remember
them if I can get off the top of my head
it's a lesson I teach in the entre
leadership but I think I've got it
stored in my brain you need to set goals
in several areas of your life Sigma
Ziegler used to call it The Wheel of
Life the different areas of our life and
they affect each other so if you do one
without doing if you win in one area
without winning in the other you can
destroy the other so you let you so like
for instance you set career goals and
you set family goals if you win at your
career and all you do is work and you
never see your family your family will
leave and so but if all you do spend
time with your family you'll starve to
death
well nurtured but started to starve to
death I mean you'll be emotionally
fabulous but you'll be skinny because
you don't work and you can't eat right
so that's two of them as set goals in
the family area set goals in the career
area another overlapping one would be
the financial area obviously we'd talk
about that one physical goals are you
gonna run a marathon this year or lose
weight or bench 300 I don't know
whatever none of those are on my list
but anyway maybe the cookies maybe
chocolate chip cookies but the anyway so
physical goals family goals career goals
financial goals spiritual goals would be
one
there's another one I'm trying to be
social social that's the one I always
forget yeah I don't have any friends I
wouldn't have any friends if I wasn't
married so I yeah yeah social goals and
so it's it you know just sit down and go
okay what are we gonna do from a social
perspective this year I mean you know
those people you tell them you're always
going to have lunch with them and you
never do let's just make a list of them
and say we really do want to see them
now the ones you're lying to and you
don't want to see then it's not I'm
talking about but yeah let's do you
don't plan to that's not what I'm
talking about but the ones you really do
want to see and you need to set some
physical goals if you don't take care of
your physical body it'll mess up your
career because you'll be in the hospital
you know and so exercise is a physical
goal obviously to accomplish some our
exercises a method of accomplishing a
physical goal so let's see if I got them
let's see financial career physical
family spiritual social I think that's
it I think there were six of them on
that wheel six spokes on that wheel if I
remember and okay yeah and then to set
goals on an addition to that will just
keep going you need to have goals that
are specific and measurable I want to
lose weight is not specific it is
measurable but it's not specific so how
much weight do you want to lose thirty
pounds okay now we're starting to get a
goal the third thing is goals need to
have a time frame I want to lose 30
pounds great how often and how many
times and how long are you gonna take
I wanna lose 30 pounds in 90 days and
now we're starting to get a goal because
that's ten pounds a month doing that
pounds a week I want to make $100,000
win over 40 years no in one year oh okay
that's 8333 dollars a month that's 20
100 bucks a week so now how are we going
to get about that that's a hundred
thousand dollars a year so if that's
what you want to make that's you start
breaking it down as soon as you have a
time frame it divides out if it's
specific measurable has a time frame the
fourth one isn't the goals have to be
yours you have to own them my wife wants
me to lose weight that won't work
my wife wants my career to go better
that won't work my mommy wants me to be
a dentist I don't want to be your
and I want you to be a dentist because
you're called to do it I don't wanna go
to your church because your daddy told
you to be a preacher but because your
heavenly father called you now that
would be good I'll go to that church so
that kind of thing it needs to be your
goals you need to own them my boss told
me I had to do this it's not a goal
that's a quota and so time has to have a
timeframe has to be measurable has to be
specific need to be your goals and the
last thing is they need to be in writing
write them down I mean if you don't
write it down it's not gonna happen the
Bible says in the back to to write the
vision and make it plain and so write it
down put it in front of you put it on
your computer screen when he comes open
put it on your car mirror I don't care
but write it out and something happens
when you write it out and I don't just
put it in a drawer laid around where you
can see it but I want to make hundred
thousand dollars this year on those
thirty pounds in the next 90 days I'm
going to do these six things to make my
marriage better this year we're going to
have dinner with 12 couples this year 12
families this year or whatever we're
gonna you know intellectual goals that's
another one I left out now I want to I'm
gonna take some classes I want to read a
nonfiction book a month which by the way
the average millionaire does and they
can't tell you who got thrown off the
island or who can't dance they're not
sure about reality TV whether it's
reality or not so they don't watch it
and so on you just you adopt the habit
patterns and take the steps to hit those
goals once you do those five things to
hit those six or seven areas you were
right it was seven because intellectual
was the seventh and so what are you
going to feed your intellect read read
read read read by the way there's
several ways to take in content now I
appreciate all of you listening to my
podcast I appreciate you watching our
videos on YouTube it does not stimulate
the brain the same way that reading does
you brain fires differently the
electrons in your brain fire differently
when you read and it stimulates thoughts
and stimulates vision and dreams and
ambition much more than media does
meaning audio or video media or mediums
and so even an audio book doesn't do
what reading a book does
I'll be reading a book and have seven
ideas about something that don't have
anything to do about what I'm reading
about that's partly because I'm a little
bit a DD but but it's it what it does is
it fires the brain up it gets your brain
moving and I'm not talking about reading
fiction I read fiction too
I read a lot of fiction makes airplanes
fly faster but makes a beach get calmed
down all that but but if I'm reading a
business book or a leadership book or a
nonfiction book on parenting or marriage
or whatever area I'm wanting to study
right then if fires your brain up and
you start having ideas that have nothing
to the subject matter that you're
reading a lot of times and I've had that
happen many times I'll fill up a yellow
pad with ideas while I'm reading a book
and it's nothing to do with what I'm
reading so just keep the yellow pad
there that's not that's not
I'm joking about being a DD it's not a D
it's what happens to the physical makeup
of your brain while you're doing that
changes things so it's very difficult to
keep your brain fired up if you never
read so some interesting discussions
Adam thanks for calling in now let me
get up on my soapbox a little bit